we're asked to find the product 2x plus
8 times 2x minus 8. so there's two ways
to do it we can just multiply it out
like we've always done but this is
actually a special pattern this is a
special pattern where we have an a
plus a b where a in this case is 2x and
b is 8. and then we have that being
multiplied by a minus b where once again
a is 2x and b is equal to 8. and
whenever you have this pattern it
simplifies to
a squared minus b squared and i'll show
you at the end of this video why it is
but we can just do this pattern we have
a plus b times a minus b 2x plus 8 times
2x minus 8. so this will simplify based
on this pattern right here to a squared
which is 2x
squared minus b squared minus
squared so what does this get us this
gets us 2 squared is 4 times x squared
minus 8 squared minus 64. and we're done
now let's prove to ourselves that this
actually works let's multiply a plus b
times a minus b
so if we take
if we take a plus b
times
a minus b
a minus b we can first distribute this
we can distribute the a plus b to on to
each of these terms so it'll be this
whole purple a plus b
times that a and then the whole purple a
plus b times that negative b
so you could view it as
a
times
a plus b
and then you can have
minus b
minus b times a plus b
a plus b all i did is i distributed this
onto each of those that times that
that's right there
plus that times that that's right there
and then we can distribute again a times
a is a squared a times b is a b
negative b times a is negative
a b or negative b a same thing negative
b times b is negative b squared and then
you see you have a positive a b and a
negative a b they cancel out and you're
left with a squared minus b squared so
we could have actually done this little
exercise with 2x plus 8 and 2x minus 8
and we would have gotten this but it's
neater just to see the general pattern
anytime you have a plus b times a minus
b is going to be a squared minus b
squared in this case a is 2x so a
squared is 4x squared
b is 8 so b squared is 64.